[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté avec toutes ces belles choses que
fait aujourd'hui un plein de bike par
les anglais oui là je fais des progrès
je m'instruis y va ça bravo oui c'est
une grande nouveauté
bien sûr et qu'est ce que c'est votre
affaire hé bé c'est une mélange de
crustacés qu'on va faire cuire vous
allez voir comment et sept américains et
c'est excellent ça écouter cet
extraordinaire et ça me passionne ça
m'intéresse
oui parce que votre affaire qu'on fait
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique on a
raconté que les indiens de ça sur les
plages autrefois il était plus
intelligent encore elle est oui mais
peut-être qu'on le faisait aussi autant
de l'homme des cavernes à votre ancêtre
de pas très loin d'ici là on va voir
comment on le faire ça c'est parait
intéressant et on peut encore le faire
aujourd'hui parce que c'est très actuel
maintenant ça c'est pas américaine a
enfin nous allons voir en est simple on
doit voir toutefois vous ne faites pas
que cette recette vous et d'en faire des
frères au fenouil et à l'ail
très bien alors qu'est-ce qu'il nous
faudra pour tout ça et bien nous four ça
c'est pour décoration parce que
tellement beau qu'on a mis sa vie nous
faut du banc vert face à ces divers le
buzz et voilà il le faut même hervé
léger c'est bon tu vas d'aquitaine mais
ya partout du besoin d'un combat
championnat il nous faut de l'oignon des
citrons verts du fenouil des huîtres des
praires de l'aneth vous oui avez-vous
douté dans tous les sens c'est à dire
des langoustines des homards on montre
de nous qu'il est beau alors celui là il
est doux il y eut bassin d'arcachon
voyez c'est américaine
mais naturellement on pourrait aussi
citer les noms oui bien fermé puis et
homard du maine
voilà en amérique où ils ont dit omar
fabuleux aussi et délicieux parfum on
n'est pas les seuls noirs et bonne
chance là vous avez les clubs réclament
souvent là et des carottes et des
tourteaux du dormeur où elle a montré le
nous n'avons pas besoin de regarder
dessous je suis sûr que c'est un mal non
et tellement gros et regardez moi de ce
grand bonhomme il est en train de sabrer
dans des algues
il est beau il est superbe ouais si vous
parlez mérité l'argent mais pour la
journée mais pour la journée we are ne
le faisons pas magnifique amis alors par
quoi commence et on est bien on va faire
le plein bagdad bambèye d'abord comment
fait on ça c'est plus difficile
enfin deux trous bon si on a la chance
d'être sur la plage c'est patrick
gonthier vous la plante vient de la
pêche en bassin d'arcachon et de la
pêche on a tous parce qu'on peut faire
avec ce qu'on veut là on en trouve au
plateau mais on peut faire révéler que
les coquillages je connais de tout ce
qu'on a stocké à ces crustacés ce qu'on
est plus qu un seul verre bon mais quand
on a la chance d'avoir ça c'est fait
alors enfin tout comme ça à peu près un
joli tour dans le suivant l'importance
qu'on a deux affaires et cuir à paris
mais on ramasse les caler derrière on
met une couche de pierre bien de bien
plateau fin de ce tour quand on fait du
feu ont fait du feu en fait du feu par
un 3 heures de temps
alors imaginez trois ans le temps quand
on s'aime
car demander plus tassé il fait clair de
lune ben tu sais je vous demande pas je
les regarde pas d'accord allez vous avez
dressé avec pierrot dans votre jeune est
à dire hier on va pas vous demander ce
que vous faisiez parlement y avait 26
voyons combat
alors bon patient concernant vous
pourriez faire aussi dans le jardin
aussi on peut faire ça à la maison vous
faites un trou pareil vous allez
chercher des galets et vous faites du
feu trois heures de temps au moins
minimum parce qu'il faut que la pierre
soit 102 chose de chaud devrait il ya
peut-être le quart de lune n'y a pas la
douceur du sable alors c'est quand même
moins bien oui mais il ya tout va bien
et il son côté nous n'avons ni le sable
ni les jardins dans cette cuisine qu'est
ce que vous avez fait mais nous avons la
cheminée micheline ça va aller au ciné
on va faire dans la cheminée
ces actes que vous ne manquiez je
commence à mettre des arcs dans ma
bassine danser comme si je faisais mon
marché oui car tout les orgues voix
après je prends j'avais préparé un vrai
besoin
il comprend bien moi un grave le homard
les langoustines
bien sûr la haine d'autrui
des huîtres quelques toiles à quelques
claroix le maïs parce que cet américain
environ van reeth c'est un plan
américain cela ça q très vite sa n 2
voilà des êtres et j'attaque les pierres
sont chauffés à blanc maïté comme il
faut vous avez tous fait combien de
verser dans la cheminée
du feu oui oui faut donner aux galets du
coup de balai et qu'est ce que vous
allez faire maintenant vous allez voir
vous allez voir ce que je vais faire un
peu de ménage un peu de ménage la sambre
et la sambre qui était dessus
oui voilà ensuite je vais mettre mon
papier il se trouvait là a déclaré en
papier alu de plusieurs dépêches
oui pour pas que ça se peut que ça féret
le coup et puis tout simplement où vous
restez pas ça vivant quand même
non non non les avants on m'attend vieux
vous inquiétez pas si un peu peur là non
le homard de maïs les coquillages
regarder ça tout ça sera cuir gentiment
la halle à l'école a découvert comme ça
ça à prendre une éternité accueillir
mais c'est un petit potager magnifique
soleil voilà regarder ça alors
maintenant je hiver les algues à tiens
ça ça donne du goût mais il en faut bien
un
il faut pas dire qu'on connaît ses
limites ça va dégager un peu de vapeur
et ses arguments il ya des preuves est
toujours les maîtres ont gardé mois et
oui je vais même en rajouter d'autres je
vais réserver un bon matelas d'halloween
tout frais cela regardez moi ça et ça va
me soutenir la chaleur oui et alors en
plus j'ai pu desservir tout peut faire
sauver des serviettes de bain mouillés
et wii puis syrte à bord de la place
c'est encore mieux parce qu'on les 30
dans l'eau mais rejeté les autres années
voilà c'est tout à fait ce qu'il faut
c'est un menu qui se fait tout seul
voilà ses vols et là ça va rester comme
ça combien une oeuvre de temps 1h
regardez seulement de pain de travail
pendant ce qu'on va nous pouvons
peut-être faire les praires à l'ail au
foehn et humanité mais bien sûr alors
comment allez-vous faire héberger vis de
l'ue doliveux dans la poêle
la gym et de l'oignon coupé très très
petit à petit
c'est bien vous était bien sûr déçu
après je vais mettre mes carottes pour
ça ça va colossales sont en fait comme
on dit en brunoise les tout petits
petits petits dés et parce qu'il faut
que ça puisque très vite
allez hop un petit peu plus voilà là je
vais y mettre
je savais pas vraiment où peut il faut
toujours certains jeux sera dévoilée
vous devez tout ça alors je vais mettre
mes gousses d'ail entières
oui alors je vais en mettre 3 3 à la
lumière ça va donner bon goût là aussi
et puis mercenaire je vais me nettoyer
vous ne mettez parler de celui qu
d'abord quand même nous ne ferions pas
beaucoup je vais remettre très peu dans
le coeur alors qu'aux petites lamelles
juste pour donner un petit concert vip
art fair voilà c'est tout voir j'ai fait
le tout faux laissé fondre un peu tout
ça roule et s'effondre tout ça mais pour
pas perdre de temps on va nettoyer des
prêts à oui parce qu'elle est prête il
ya toujours un petit peu de sable dedans
non à toutes les tous les coquillages à
peu près ceux de marla moi j'ai mis de
l'eau salée ah oui voila j'ai mis de
l'eau salée parce que s'ils avaient des
preuves dans l'autre l'air est bon les
ressorts fade comme tout alors là on met
sur la une petite brosse ont entravé la
petite brosse voilà vous voyez on les
laisse que la caverne les temples plein
de reculs des rainures logo bien regagné
ayant nettoyé passe autrement c'est très
désagréable
voilà alors ça c'est revenu oui je veux
jouer à ça ça fait mal et comme on dit
et grands faits de servira de cuir 3d
voir comment ça finira qu'est-ce que
vous ajoutez de dope je vais te le faire
alors on appris du vin rouge est
aujourd'hui à peu corsé ses débuts zèle
de buzet du vins d'aquitaine bienvenue
en mai
en avoir la haine assez et puis je vais
y mettre les frères d'armes
maintenant voilà c'est tout je vais
démettre la voie lente ceci est la terre
et oui c'est sale et oui en effet la
voilà il vous à les couvrir et je vais
couvrir
on n'a rien oublié je ne pense pas c'est
bon il faut la peindre 3 4 minutes
jusqu'à ce que les frères soit ouverte
des lbo ouvertes de 8 3 4 minutes on
passe et maïté j'ai envie de voir ce
qu'il ya dessous moi on enlève le
couvercle on va voir
voilà elles se sont ouvert toutes les
copies sont ouvertes alors le plat est
terminée là non on va mettre un peu de
paprika bien par dessus vous allez de
percer pour donner bien de la couleur et
du goût oui de la crème fraîche
connaître de belles cuvées et on tourne
on tourne un mélange et on mélange bien
tout comme on dit en aquitaine
voilà regardez cette couleur lie de vin
et c'est parti comme un tout et la
pauvreté et c ski fo estime qu'il existe
concrètement qu'est ce qu'elle sait
regarder ça c 'est joli et à étudier là
où la cité nord non on va y mettre la
main maintenant on avait préparé les amp
et enfin un peu de chemin on va sous peu
une ride un peu de repos
il n'y a pas de raison que moi la lie et
la wii mais il est peut-être temps
d'aller voir ce qui se passe avec sous
la serviette avec notre club est bien
sûr quoi x est cuit vas-y tu es un bon
il ya eu le bonheur moi je suis inquiète
que il sépare ce cas là dessous il ya
une bonne heure que ça y est les galets
et et qu il faut il y afin de raison oui
bien sûr que c'est cuit
regardez ça c'est là dessous c'est pas
beau ce show écoutez on est comme ça
grésille
notre année commence à cui ararat c'est
extraordinaire mais bien sûr toutes les
chambres sont celles de son cd simple
sont les meilleurs voilà regarder ça
c'est joli c'est étonnant c'est superbe
dans la cheminée mais en plein air ça
doit être encore plus fort mais gardent
ça c'est une belle soirée
maïté fera quand même pas oublier
peut-être de dire au revoir à nos avis
mais bien sûr les praires à l'ail et au
fenouil sont terminées maïté cet
appétissant
c'est à dire bon à manger lequel vient
il me semble qu'elles sont cuites comme
il faut un
il faut pas qu'elle soit très sèche et
alors là c'est comme est faux c'est bien
oui et bien ça y est une excellente
recette de plus délicieux notre clan
bien précis il est parfait aussi parfait
aussi ça c'est pas le homard les
coquillages qui ont ouvert à la chaleur
les huîtres juste comme il faut
le crabe impeccable merveilleux amusez
vous quand vous aurez l'occasion surtout
ne manquez pas tant de plaisir au revoir
merci à bientôt
[Musique]